[Applaus]
[Musik]
die ukraine ist so was wie der boris der
kernstaaten jedes mal wenn man die
medien was von ihnen hört kann man davon
ausgehen dass etwas schlimmes passiert
ist denn wenn wir an die ukraine denken
denken wir an tschernobyl den krieg mit
russland oder den korruptionsskandal der
zu trumps erstens erhebungsverfahren
führte tatsächlich ist die ganze
ukrainische geschichte ein einziges
trauerspiel
[Musik]
kleiner tipp am rande wenn du eines
tages gefeiert wird ach du dich verlässt
oder die ein anderes unglück widerfährt
ließ etwas über die geschichte der
ukraine oder schon wir dieses video
nochmal an
du wirst dich hinterher mit sicherheit
besser fühlen wenn deine persönliche
misere der relevant vorkommen wir reden
hier über eines der ärmsten länder
europas welches eigentlich wohlhabend
sein könnte gemessen am
bruttoinlandsprodukt heute so arm wie
die bürger von el salvador oder
turkmenistan
aber all dies könnte sich ändern und wir
sind dabei gerade jetzt den moment der
wahrheit zu erleben in den kommenden
monaten steht der präsident der ukraine
vor allem großen willen von denen die
zukunft seines landes abhängt und am
ende des videos was genau verstehen was
wir damit mal aber warum ist die ukraine
eigentlich so haben einige werden sagen
das ist auch ganz klar die ukraine
gehört das ausprobiert union
sie hatten eine kommunistische
vergangenheit und sind jetzt eben abend
dran aber es gibt viele andere länder
die auch als teile des kommunistischen
ostblocks komplett herunter
gewirtschaftet waren und jetzt
wohlhabender demokratien mit hoher
lebensqualität sind polen tschechien
sind heute prosperierende länder mit
einem lebensstandard der mit dem anderer
europäischer länder vergleichbar ist und
kurioserweise wird es in polen und
tschechien jetzt nur so von ukrainern
bookrunner
die für ein paar monate kommen so zu
arbeiten zum beispiel auf dem bau um
dann wieder in ihr land zurückzukehren
tatsächlich soll er sich die
geldtransfers ukrainischer gastarbeiter
in die heimat fast zwölf prozent des
gesamten ukrainischen produkt
inlandsprodukt es wird geschätzt dass
mehr als zehn millionen ukrainer im
ausland arbeiten und sei es nur für ein
paar monate im jahr und ich sage es wird
geschätzt weil der größte teil der
ukrainischen wirtschaft in formeln einen
schatten ökonomie ist vergesst nicht
dass man über land sprechen das sich
derzeit in offenen krieg mit russland
befindet aber nein das ist nicht der
einzige grund warum sie so arm sind die
fragen die wir uns heute stellen laufen
also warum ist die ukraine so haben was
ist los in diesem land in dem es 30
jahre nach dem ende des kommunismus noch
was schlimmer ist als zu zeiten der
sowjetunion portal werden wir all diese
fragen beantworten aber zuerst einen
kurzen blick auf die geschichte werfen
[Musik]
der kapitalismus der nie ankam
hast du schon mal von der antonow 225
gehört sie ist nichts geringeres als das
größte flugzeug der welt übrigens wenn
du alle technischen details dieses
liegenden kurses erfahren willst kannst
du dir dazu ein video unseren
schwesterkanal im neckar projects
anschaut nur dieses technische
wunderwerk wird komplett in der ukraine
hergestellt die ukraine ist eines von
neun ländern dieser welt die vollkommen
autark flugzeuge herstellen können ohne
teile aus dem ausland kaufen zu lassen
sie verfügen über die gesamte
produktionskette der luft und
raumfahrtindustrie innerhalb ihrer
eigenen grenze wenige länder können mit
zusätzlichen logi aufwarten und trotz
all dem ist die ukraine so anbietet
ministern oder el salvador
falls du das immer noch nicht
faszinierend findet kommt hier noch ein
weiterer fun fact die ukraine hat
natürliche ressourcen aller art koran
und alle arten von metallen und der
ukrainische boden ist eine der
fruchtbarsten für alle arten von
landwirtschaft die sogenannte tschernow
sam oder schwarzer erde ist eine art
bogen der scheinbar fantastisch für den
anbau von feldfrüchten ist in der tat
war die ukrainer jahrzehnte lang die
kornkammer der sowjetunion aber dem
keiner hatte viel zu leiden unter den
nazis wie unter den sowjets während star
alliance ära wally bevölkerung einer der
schrecklichsten hunderte der geschichte
ausgesetzt den sogenannten holodomor und
nach dem fall des kommunismus stand die
ukraine als eine der ersten
postsowjetischen staaten dar
ein land das auch in zwei große teile
gespalten war in russischsprachigen
östlichen regionen und den westen in
denen die menschen ukraine sprechen du
dir vorstellen kannst geht diese
spaltung geht auch über die sprache
hinaus die kleine sprechrolle group
möchte dass die ukraine eine
marktwirtschaft die russischsprachige
bevölkerung möchte eine zentralisierte
wirtschaft und handelsbeziehungen mit
russland aufrechterhalten all das
erklärt warum es in der ukraine nie
einen wirklichen übergang zum
kapitalismus gegeben hat der beweis
dafür ist dass die bis heute über 3600
staatliche unternehmen haben und all das
hat damit zu tun auf welche art und
weise die ukraine ihre wirtschaft
privatisiert hat
[Musik]
schon mal der sowjetkommunismus basiert
auf einer komplett staatlich gelenkten
wirtschaft das heißt alle unternehmen
waren im staat besitzt von den großen
energieunternehmen bis zur letzten
schokoladenfabrik daher war der
wichtigste schritt beim übergang vom
kommunismus und kapitalismus die
privatisierung fast all diese
unternehmen aus diesem grund haben die
ukraine polen ist in tschechien und fast
alle länder des ehemaligen ostblocks in
den neunzigerjahren
privatisierungsprozess durchlaufen doch
wie wir auch bis heute nicht immer sagen
steckt der teufel im detail
lasst uns mal zum besseren verständnis
kunst der aktivierungs prozess in
tschechien mit dem in der ukraine
vergleichen
weißt du diesen kanal schon eine weile
abonniert hat erinnerst du dich
vielleicht noch in unserer video über
die sehr erfolgreiche privatisierung der
polnischen wirtschaft falls nicht worauf
wartest du noch druck schnell den abo
button und die kleine glocke damit du
keines unserer update verpasst aber
zurück zu unserer geschichte
[Musik]
nach dem fall des kommunismus
versteigerte die tschechische regierung
die meisten stars unternehmen in form
von anteilsscheinen sogenannten cocos
diese gebohrt wurden dann zu einem sehr
erschwinglichen preis weit unter dem
tatsächlichen gesamtwert der unternehmen
an die bürger verkauft jeder einwohner
durfte in nehren privatisierungs runden
ein bestimmtes pro kopf kontingent
dieser coupons erwerben tatsächlich
griffen damals 80 prozent der bürger zu
und erhielten für ihre coupons später
direkt unternehmensanteile an den
privatisierten mit anderen worten die
regierung ermöglicht es allen bürgern
kapitalisten zu werden und sich sehr
leicht an denen zu privatisierenden
unternehmen zu beteiligen und auch wenn
dabei nicht alles super toll ich und ist
sehr sehr viele betrugsfälle gab
deutschland kennt dieses jahr aus der
privatisierung der ddr wirtschaft durch
die treuhand all dies erklärt warum
schlechthin heute dann ist der egalität
ersten länder der welt ist auch wenn es
nur wenige wissen tscheche ist weltweit
eines jener länder mit der geringsten
kluft zwischen arm und reich es
übertrifft damit sogar die
skandinavischen länder
denn bis heute ist die aktion erst gut
in tschechien höher als in anderen
ländern
circa 25 prozent im vergleich zu 15 in
deutschland das heißt magic bürger
profitieren von den gewinnen der
unternehmen in ihrem land die zweite
säule der tschechischen privatisierung
bestand darin gute ausländische
investoren ins land zu holen die nicht
nur kapital mitbringen sondern auch viel
know how und westliche
unternehmenskultur auf diese weise zum
beispiel übernahm volkswagen den
traditionsreichen tschechische
automobilhersteller skoda heute
umsatzstärkstes firma und exportmeister
des landes in der ukraine jedoch lief
das alles vollkommen anders
ja es stimmt der staat hat dort auch
privatisierungskurs an seine bürger
verkauft aber mit einem entscheidenden
unterschied stellte uns vor wesen
einiger bürger in den neunzigerjahren
und arbeiten in der schokoladenfabrik
über die wir vorher gesprochen haben
da stand erzählt uns dass er das
unternehmen privatisieren wird und dass
du jetzt umgerechnet 1.500 dollar einen
anteil kaufen können wenn das
unternehmen privatisiert wird können wir
unseren kleinen coup gegen ein
aktienpaket eintauschen
so weit so gut das problem ist aber dass
dieses stück papier ebenso lange nichts
wert ist bis das unternehmen dann
wirklich privatisiert wird und wir es
gegen echte aktien eintauschen können
und jetzt stell dir vor dieser moment
wird immer weiter in die zukunft
verschoben
als diese sich dann wieder gehen ist und
irgendwie kommt der umtausch nicht
zustande
warum ja die eliten welche die neue
ukraine agieren sind eben die gleichen
die schon zu zeiten der sowjetunion an
der macht
waren sie haben so den namen geändert
aus der kommunistischen ist die
sozialdemokratische partei geworden mit
den gleichen gesichter in reichen ideen
und gleichen interesse das ergebnis dass
du einen gutschein gekauft hast der zu
nichts gut war und das ist der moment in
dem man organisch auftaucht ein herr
namens patrick schenk werte diesen gut
denn er wird später noch wichtig sein
nur dieser petro poroschenko und viele
andere wie er ist ein herr der gut mit
der regierung verhandelt ist und
zusammen mit seinen freunden und
verwandten etwas geld eingesammelt hat
um diese leute herkommt so sagt das
kleine stück papier das der hand hält
ist doch wertlos und du brauchst geld
nicht wahr
ja ich gebe dir 100 dollar dafür du
kannst dann wenigstens diesem monat eine
miete bezahlt und was machen wir es
verkaufen es ihnen und sind noch dankbar
dafür dass wir unsere mieten können
tja und kurz nachdem porsche die coupons
von mir und meinen kollegen gekauft hat
kommt die große überraschung der staat
kommt und privatisiert dann doch auf
einmal ganz schnell die
schokoladenfabrik mit anderen worten für
sehr wenig geld ist bei schenker
eigentümer einer schokoladenfabrik
geworden und so wurde 1996 die
außengruppe geboren die heute der
führende hersteller von süßigkeiten in
der ukraine
in der tat ist herr poroschenko ist der
schokoladen kündigt bekannt nun
poroschenko ist eines von vielen
beispielen für ukrainische oligarchen
und eine vorstellung zu geben es wird
geschätzt dass sich ganze 85 prozent des
ukrainischen vermögens in den händen von
euch gar nicht und egal schon sind wie
eine dystopische version des american
dream vom tellerwäscher zum lehrer der
aber nur wenn du politisch gut verletzt
bist und keinerlei skrupel besitz zu
schmieren wie nur geht
erinnerst du dich zum beispiel an die
landwirtschaftliche fruchtbare china sei
nun was das gesamte ackerland in der
ukraine befindet sich in händen von nur
25 großgrundbesitzern und du wirst sagen
wo ist das problem so funktioniert nun
mal der freie markt mein freundlichen
nur so funktionär sicherlich nicht bis
vor kurzem war der kauf und verkauf von
landwirtschaftlichen flächen in der
ukraine sogar verboten mit anderen
worten die oligarchen haben das land
während privatisierung übernommen und
das gesetz schützt sie damit sie es
behalten können egal was passiert da ist
nix mit markt und das ergebnis die
ukrainische landwirtschaft ist völlig
unproduktiv wo sie über über fruchtbares
land verfügt produzieren 70 prozent der
ukrainischen landwirte nur halb so viele
projekte wie die farmer in den
vereinigten staaten
natürlich sorgten die oligarchen auch
dafür dass der staat möglichst wenig
ausländische investoren ins land lässt
die in ihren firmen westliche praktiken
einführen und sie dann am klaus stören
würden das ergebnis sind unzählige
korruptionsskandal in staatlichen
unternehmen und jemand eine vorstellung
davon zu geben
das größte unternehmen des landes
naftogas naftogaz ist das ukrainische
gas unternehmen das dem staat gehört
laut einem us think tank verursacht die
korruption in diesem unternehmen alleine
ein schaden von mehr als drei milliarden
dollar pro jahr
und natürlich verursachen all diese
großen schäden direkt gewaltige verluste
allein im jahr 2014 beliefen sich die
verluste von naftogaz auf sechs prozent
des ukrainischen bruttoinlandsprodukts
[Musik]
anderen worden die ukraine ist zu einem
großen teil wegen der korruption der
ukraine selbst arm aber ich weiß was
viele von euch denken war sehr technisch
gesehen befinde sich die ukraine im
krieg mit russland ganze regionen wurden
von russland über hand das wirklich
keine wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen und
das hat es und wir werden uns das jetzt
mal näher ansehen
[Musik]
der moment der wahrheit solltest du die
letzten jahre nicht als einziger in
einer höhle verbracht haben wirst du
wissen dass russland und ukraine auf
erbitterte weise verfeindet sind von
bruder soll kann zu erzfeinden quasi das
gegenteil der historischen leistung
deutschlands und frankreichs der
konflikt schwelte schon lange und
beachten offen mit den euro x der antrag
testen aus tausende von jungen menschen
gingen auf die straße um gegen die putin
freundliche ukrainischen regierung zu
protestieren
sie wurden gewaltsam von der polizei
unterdrückt aber es gelang ihnen
schließlich die po russische regierung
von viktor janukowitsch besteht
was sicherlich nicht weißt ist warum das
alles eigentlich angefangen hat damals
sogar bis 2014 wollten die meisten
ukrainer nicht der nato beitreten
zu dieser zeit war russland der
wichtigste handelspartner des landes was
ist also passiert dass diese situation
eine solche 180 grad wendung genommen
habt nun ist begann alles wegen dieser
nachricht
[Musik]
gerade dass es gespräche über eu
handelspartner putin das tauziehen
gewinnt um es zusammenzufassen bis 2013
nach russland der wichtigste
handelspartner der ukraine russland
verkaufte sein gas an die ukraine und
die ukraine lieferte ihre metalle und
die getreide nach russland durch die
ukraine wollte nicht mehr so abhängig
von kreml sein das hat sie dazu gebracht
ein freihandelsabkommen mit der
europäischen union ausgehandelt ende
2013 stand der präsident der ukraine
kurz davor einen solchen vertrag zu
unterzeichnen
aber putin hat in unter druck gesetzt
damit er einen rückzieher macht
erinnerst du dich dass ich dir erzählt
habe dass die ukraine in zwei hälften
geteilt ist nur die ukrainisch frage
hättest du das beet gegen diesen vertrag
als fahrrad und das ist was die euro mal
daran proteste zum ausdruck brachte
diese proteste führten dazu dass
janukowitsch stürzte das problem dabei
jetzt fühlte sich wieder die große
sprünge hefte verraten und was sind die
regionen mit den meisten russen sprachen
menschen im ganzen land sind jetzt gut
lukas ist diese drei regionen waren
jetzt beleidigt und wollten sich vom
rest der ukraine abspalten
denn jetzt kommt na ja
russland unterstützt artisten und so
brachte ukrainische krieg aus
über all das werden einem anderen video
sprechen heute konzentrieren wir uns auf
die wirtschaft denn die erste
wirtschaftliche folge dieses kriegs war
der abbruch der handelsbeziehungen mit
russland will das bitte mal einen blick
auf diese klasse
[Applaus]
werden hier sehen kannst vor die ukraine
während der gleichen zeit im handel mit
russland herunter und den mit der eu
hoch so dass diese ihr wichtigster
handelspartner und viele von euch würden
denken dass die einen ganz neuen anfang
zu dem kleinen bedeutete eine
veränderung des kurses hin zu mehr
marktwirtschaft das ende der prognose
von uniqa hier richtig nun nicht
wirklich rate mal wer später präsident
kleine wurde
schokoladen kündigt porsche mit die
präsidentschaftswahlen in der ukraine
aber die gewalt geht weiter das ist
richtig die ukraine ersetzte einfach der
russische oligarch durch die ukrainische
oligarch alles musste sich ändern damit
alles beim alten bleiben kann
seitdem hat die regierung den bürgern
ein anti korruptionsprogramme nach dem
anderen versprochen mehrere
zivilgesellschaftliche plattformen sind
entstanden um die eklatantesten fälle
vor gericht zu bringen
gleichzeitig haben die eliten karriere
versucht viele dieser vorhaben
auszubremsen und so geht es weiter bis
und was ist dann passiert aufgepasst
generalreinigung erinnerst du dich an
das erste amtsenthebung verfahren gegen
trump wie du dich vielleicht erinnert
fing alles damit an dass trump der
kleine angeblich etwas militärhilfe
versprochen hat den austausch für die
eröffnung eine untersuchung gegen beiden
das war 2009 10
und so lernt die welt den neuen
ukrainischen präsidenten kennen obwohl
u-teams der wende mich an petro
poroschenko du hast mich zu einer
debatte eingeladen und dachte ist ich
würde angst haben und mich verstecken
ich bin aber nicht wie du im jahr 2014
vor dass morgan freeman nach denen in
den hsv so toll den us-präsidenten
gespielt hat danach auf die idee käme
tatsächlich wird das amt ist präsident
der vereinigten staaten zu kandidieren
also auch im juli läuft nun genau das
wahlweise lynskey der fall gesprächen
über einen schauspieler der durch seine
rolle als präsident der kleine in einer
fernsehserie berühmt wurde und auf dem
höhepunkt seiner schauspielkarriere
kandidierte er tatsächlich bei der wahl
des staatspräsidenten nur wenige hätten
auch seinen erfolg als reallife
politiker gerettet
doch entgegen aller vorhersagen gewann
im mai 2009 10 die wahl gegen den
ungarischen petro poroschenko seine
botschaft lautete ich bin weder pro
russisch noch anti russisch meine
fantasien die korruption und oligarchen
und das erklärt warum unter seiner
regierung maßnahmen wie die folgende
verabschiedet wurden
[Musik]
ukrainische parlament verabschiedet ein
gesetz zur öffnung des markts für
ackerland ab juli 2021 erinnerst du dich
an dem gesetz zum schutze der
ukrainischen oligarchen nun nach und
nach schafft die neue ukrainische
regierung diese ab februar 2091 wollen
sie die konten eines weiteren pro
russischen oligarchen des milliardärs
gibt sich ein als diese maßnahmen sind
sehr wichtig für die ukraine und sie
dienen nicht nur das um das land zu
säubern
sie sind auch wichtig internationale
hilfe zu erhalten so beispiel hat der
ukraine mit meinen fünf milliarden
dollar kredite vom internationalen
währungsfonds gebeten aber dieser kredit
wird nur dann ausgezahlt wenn die
ukraine ist mit ihrem kampf gegen die
funktion ernst und ich weiß dass viele
von euch an dieser stelle denken
selensky muss ein held für die ukrainer
seien ein mann der volkswohnung
gerechtigkeit gegen die interessen aller
erdenklichen organischen durchsetzt
richtig nun das ist er nicht so lenski
begann seine präsidentschaft mit hohen
beliebtheitswerten aber im letzten jahr
stürzten diese ab außerdem musste seine
partei bei den letzten kommunalwahlen
herbe niederlage einstecken
viele würden denken dass dies alles auf
das kroner virus zurückzuführen seien
schwierige zeigt nun meine ganze
regieren eben aber vergesst nicht dass
wir über die ukraine sprechen
das land des ukrainischen traums wieder
amerikanischer traum nur die schlimmer
in der ukraine erfolg zu haben ohne auf
die omega schuss gesessen ist praktisch
unmöglich und das schließt auch selensky
mit einer
[Musik]
die usa verhängen sanktionen gegen den
ukrainischen oligarchen kolakowski wegen
angeblicher korruption und an dieser
stelle kommt der bahre moment der
wahrheit für die ukraine
du fragst dich weg kolomoisky ist nun
kein geringerer als der besitzer des
fernsehsenders auf dem see lenski
berühmt wurde und nicht nur das er ist
einer der hauptunterstützer des
aktuellen präsidenten der ukraine
mit anderen worten sogar die geiste der
korruption der ukraine braucht die
unterstützung eines oligarchen
emporzusteigen und was wird im guten
alten konarski vorgeworfen wohl außer
einem fernsehkanal besaß komorowski auch
die größte geschäftsbank der ukraine
die privatbank diese war verantwortlich
für einen gigantischen betrug bei den
columbus key seine eigene bank
ausgebildet hat um sie dann vom staat
retten zu lassen
wir sprechen hier also von korruption im
großen stil zu lasten des steuerzahlers
gesamtschaden fünfeinhalb milliarden
dollar
und dies ist der wahre moment der
wahrheit selensky normalerweise würde
eine regierung in der ukraine in solchen
fällen wegschauen um den oligarchen vor
dem gefängnis zu bewahren
es wäre nicht das erste mal dass der
ukrainische oder englische stand seiner
politischen verbindungen ungeschoren
davon kommt nun aber ließen die gerichte
das weltweite vermögen von damaskus und
der ehemalige miteigentümer der bank
weil ich in höhe von mehr als
zweieinhalb milliarden dollar einfrieren
um den schaden wieder ausgleichen zu
können
ein neues bankengesetz das
marokkanischen parlament im april 2020
verabschiedet wurde
solcom außerdem daran hindern die
kontrolle über die privatbanken
wiederzuerlangen
mit anderen worten die ukraine steckt in
einem echten dilemma der ausgang dieses
dilemmas ist entscheidend für die
zukunft des ganzen landes deswegen nun
die frage an dich wird es dieses mal
anders sein wird es der lenski zulassung
da sagt freund komorowski vor gericht
gestellt wird ist die ukraine wirklich
bereit ihren gästen aus der politik zu
verbannen und die korruption einzudämmen
ist es möglich dass die ukraine eines
tages reich sein wird teilt eure meinung
bitte die immer mit uns und allen
anderen im kommentarbereich ich hoffe
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat was
ja gibt es mit einem like teilt es mit
ihren freunden und vergesst nicht
unseren kanal zu abonnieren
mach's gut du catania und bis bald